we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships not the fake kind the real
kind I'm your host Jade warshaw joined
by Rachel Cruz h of the Rachel Cruz show
that you can find on YouTube also smart
money happy hour love that right also
the author of I'm glad for what I have
listen the list goes on oh Jade it's
good to be here with you love it all
right if you want to talk about your
life or your money you can give us a
call the number is 8825 52 5 and we will
do exactly that so let's go straight to
the phone lines where we've got Nicole
in San Francisco California what's going
on
Nicole hi Jade uh thanks for taking my
call no problem so uh my question is I
live in a very expensive area half of my
pay uh take-home check goes to my rent I
work remotely so it's kind of ridiculous
that I'm staying here and I'm thinking
about moving to mexic or moving to Texas
I see that the new constructions in
Texas they have lower interest rates
like 4.9% interest rates whereas the
interest rates right now are 7% and I'm
wondering if that's too good to be true
what why are the new construction
interest rates so low and attractive and
it's and it's should to be something
that I
pursue I have heard of um new
construction being able to offer lower
rates I they're eating that cost at some
point within the process I just love
that you're looking at your situation
and saying listen it's too expensive for
me to live here rather than continue to
struggle I'm going to embrace New
Opportunities so I don't think it's too
good to be true um does your question go
further um no yeah I was wondering if
there was like some sort of trick that
they're doing that I'm not understanding
um you know also it's a it's a big move
for me and it's something that I want to
do because I am single I just live by
myself and my dog and um if I were to
move to Texas and save money I would be
able to pay for egg freezing which is
something that my job doesn't help pay
for and it's also something that I was
like I know I don't want to finance it
they have a lot of payment plans for egg
freezing yeah and it's something that if
I moved to Texas I could save money
because I mean the even a mortgage
payment is going to be way lower than
white rent right now yeah and we're
seeing that Nicole I mean like your
situation it's very common and we're
seeing that a lot with people in these
like really high priced areas especially
where you are San Francisco the Bay Area
I mean I think it's number one right now
in the most expensive places to live but
you look at people in New York and um
you know different places and we're
seeing that people are gravitating
obviously to places that they can
actually have an affordable Life Style
and actually enjoy their money versus
being taxed High real estate being
insane
um you know and experiencing exactly
what you're experiencing so just know
you're not alone in that change even
though that's a big change you're right
I'm like when you decide to change
locations and states and uh it is you
mean you're you're uprooting your life
but I think what you have to realize is
you're doing it for a reason right
you're not necessarily running
away from something right you're running
to the life that you want and in order
to get that and do the things that you
want to do like freeze your eggs and
different things you have to have more
margin and so that means other areas of
your life are going to have to look
different in order to do that and so
you're just kind of weighing the pros
and cons and and I really applaud you
for that and and it's not easy um but
it's a reality I think a lot of people a
lot of people are facing 100% and here's
the thing even if you get there and you
realize oh man whatever they quoted me
on the interest rate it's slightly
higher or it's not quite that it's still
a better situation financially you're
going to you're still going to get more
for your money you're still going to be
able to afford owning a home or getting
a place for yourself more easily so what
are you looking to spend can you tell us
a little bit about what you're looking
to spend obviously 50 having your rent
or your mortgage be 50% of your income
is just not sustainable long term so
have you identified a number that puts
it at 25% and what you could spend in
order to get
that yeah so I was looking at homes
around 300,000 good which here I would
be 1.5 million yeah exactly it's crazy
crazy
well good for you Nicole yeah I think
it's great and I think you know um I
think Builders are feeling a little bit
of the pinch of people pulling back when
rates went up Suddenly everyone kind of
paused and they're like I'll just wait
to see if rates drop and then when they
drop yeah I they probably will they're
going to fluctuate we're in election
year things are always kind of up and
down and then when they drop everybody's
going to be out the works and I think
Jade just drives prices back up so if
anything the time is is to get in now
and you can always refinance later but
if you're in a good good position to buy
a home I'm not saying everyone needs to
rush out and buy a home um but I think
her Nicole is a great example of kind of
looking at all your options being wise
and I think yeah homes are not selling
have not sold at least in the calendar
year of 2023 like they were in 22 And1
um so I think new I think Builders are
feeling a little bit of that pinch
they're probably wanting some inventory
off their hands and if they can partner
with you know the bank and all the
things and and get a lower rate they're
probably doing that to entice people um
but obviously Nicole do your due
diligence I mean your home is for most
people the largest purchase that you
make in your lifetime so don't rush into
something because I think sometimes at
times even these new builds if they go
real quick up they may not to be the
best quality I mean you want to look at
for sure quality look at you know
different different areas and all of it
so do do your research because it's a
big change and a big purchase um and
even Nicole what you could do is since
you're moving to a brand new state you
could even rent which I know you're 100
so tired of renting right now but you
really could for 6 months to a year just
to be like okay is this the part of
Texas I want to be in and cuz once you
buy a home you're you're planted there
for a bit Yeah a completely new state
completely new culture I 100% agree with
Rachel in that I would rent Foreman I
would definitely would not do like a
long long distance home purchase of like
I wouldn't do that but to your point um
I have SE like there are new builders
that are offering those kind of
incentives on the rate um because we had
callers call in saying listen I'm trying
to sell my property and it's hard for me
cuz I'm having to compete with a new
Builder around the corner who's offering
a lower interest you know so that is
definitely happening so just do your due
diligence do your homework don't just
jump out there and buy the first thing
you see that seems right because I mean
I think it takes a while Rachel to
really get the feel of a new
neighborhood let alone a new city let
alone a new state like there's a lot on
this totally yes so yep absolutely yeah
and and I think Nicole too do I do
applaud you just for looking at options
because Jade we talk to a lot of people
and they're stuck I feel like we always
pick on California but California your
real estate is high and it's a High Cost
of Living so it's an easy place to pick
on but you know a lot of people and
they're like well I'm in California I'm
in California I'm in California this is
it this is it and you have to realize
about anything in life which again I
know uprooting your life is a big deal
so I'm not saying it flippantly but I
just love the fact that she is taking
initiative and saying hey I can make
choices in my life that's right right
and for me to have the kind of life that
I want it's going to require some
changes and so for some of you maybe
it's changing your money habits for some
of you it's changing location I mean I
don't know what it looks like for you
but this idea that I have control over
my life and I get to make decisions for
myself it's powerful that's right and
remember it's not just change for the
sake of change it's change to get you
where you want to go you want to be a
homeowner you want to have more margin
in your budget you want to be able to
enjoy your income so focus on that side
instead of focusing on the UN
uncomfortable part you know
I may not and just like think of it as
anure you're off on an adventure to
create the life you love the words of
Rachel Cruz that's right Jade this is
the Ramsay
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw this is Rachel Cruz and
we're taking your calls for the next
couple hours about your life and your
money so give us a call the number is
8825 5225 and we would be happy to
answer any of the questions that you
have uh in the meantime the Ramsey Show
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly offers a helpful winter
maintenance checklist that you can
download for free at neighborly
docomo neighborly has a local Pro to
help uh find out more at neighborly
docomomo home mom and this has been the
most stressful painful past two years of
my life with my husband making horrible
financial decisions that left us over
$5,000 in debt he owns a tree service
business making $70,000 a year and is
trying to start a mobile mechanic
business a and has purchased an
investment property we have
$163,000 mortgage on our house the rent
is a total disaster that's completely oh
the rental I'm sorry the rental is a
total disaster that's completely gutted
and we have to make payments every month
while earning no income with it and no
progress on the repairs he also bought a
brand new truck that we owe now $84,000
on and
$118,000 on a loan on a bobcat for the
business a $20,000 home equity loan that
he used to fix up the rental oh and over
$5,000 in credit cards he keeps saying
he's working on it and he is a hard
worker but has put us in a completely
impossible situation that danger that
angers me and stresses me out every
single day I work odd hours because we
can't afford Child Care nor do I want to
give up time with my kids to fix a
problem that I did not cause I feel so
stuck and hopeless M all right can we
just I'll listen I wrote it all out cuz
I'm trying to track with this okay
Heather this is not a you shouldn't be
this way she's very bitter yes as we can
tell yes very resentful which again it's
it's valid it's valid um but they feel
like not only different pages
financially but they have been split now
emotionally really seever heard I mean
she wants it sounds like she wants
nothing to do I mean nothing to do with
him oh and $5,000 in credit cards you
know I mean it is stuck and hopeless she
is she is not not in a good place which
which I get it Heather I'm like yeah all
these decisions were not wise decisions
made that he made decisions without
obviously talking to her or working as a
team so what do we do Heather what are
we going to do uh I'm seeking counsel
yes number one like I always talk to
folks about keeping their money safe
Rachel it's kind of like an acronym and
the first thing to to decide like where
you're at so s is for seeking counsel
like if you're noticing Trends within
your money with your spouse that you're
like what's going on here I feel
uncomfortable I feel unsafe financially
I feel like there's something going on
see counsil and then you're going to
find listen if there's things like
addiction abuse that's the a yeah and
then f is financial infidelity which
this is getting real close to falling
under and my in my opinion it is because
he's going out and spending massive
amounts of money without your per oh I
say permission your uh input yes yeah
without a battering and then the E of
that is you need to evaluate your
options like so that's how you go
through this and I do think that this is
a for sometimes people think Financial
infidelity is like I'm just hiding money
under the mattress or something like
that but I'm like this is a lot of money
and it sounds like we don't know Rachel
but it sounds like she has made her
objections clear and it sounds like we
could be wrong it might be something
that he did and then after the fact she
was like well how could you do that but
even still you've got this is there's
Financial issues here but when I look at
this I go this is a couple who
desperately needs to go to therapy like
they need they need help and um yeah and
he's he's obviously not living in
reality no there people like that that
we talk to and I hate to like pinpoint
people but it's the dreamers it's the oh
I have I have an idea and this idea is
going to work or I have a new idea here
and don't worry don't worry this is
surely going to and and it is it's a
level of immaturity to
when you actually make decisions in
those dreams and they don't come to
fruition you have to have reality to say
I can't do this anymore so there's a
safety here Heather that I um that I
would want for you like a point where
you're like I can't I can't keep putting
myself there's a level of danger there
in this situation that's endangering my
kids and my family that that is what it
is so that weight that you're feeling is
very very real and I just want him to
wake up to the reality and I think
what's going to have to happen is a
third party probably not going to be the
one to do it Heather sadly and I think
sometimes right I mean it's like our SP
I mean all of us feel that way with our
spouses there's always that thing that
you're like if you know this this or
this and you can you can say it and then
it ends up being nagging and it's it's
not effective but when you actually sit
down with a third party usually if it's
coming from someone else it's speaking
there but that's that's it I'm like the
the financial issues here are a symptom
of where you guys are in your marriage
and again I don't blame you Heather for
being angry and bitter but what are we
going to do with that we can't just sit
in that and continue to be in that cycle
you have have to then grow and learn are
there boundaries you put up now is there
like what do you do now what are those
steps yes that's right which is really
hard but that's the situation yeah
that's right cuz something's something's
got to change and in a situation like
this not to belabor it but there's very
little you can do to control the other
party like there's nothing you can do
really to control the other party but
you've got to sit down and figure out
okay what am I Heather going to do uh in
order to try to better the situation I
can seek out counsel I can put these
boundaries in place but then you've also
got to kind of have that point of where
you go okay where does this just get
completely toxic and you know that's up
to you and a like like Rachel said a
third party to decide and Jade we talk
all the time about couples staying on
the same page being on the same team all
of this but there's extreme situations
that we talk about a lot and I mean
Heather may be in one of those for me
where I'm like there's a point that you
have to protect yourself and your kids
right like if he's going to continue to
spend mhm I mean hundreds of thousands
of dollars like I don't want my name on
those I don't want my name on that and
if you're headed towards a I'm not
putting this I'm not putting this evil
on you but if if you're heading towards
a point where like listen I don't know
if I see us together in the future the
more he racks up like I don't want to be
any part of that because if you don't
stick together there's like I'm looking
like is this part of this going to be on
me no you know yeah so for the time
being Heather there's probably some hard
boundaries I would put up to protect you
and the kids um but work on your
marriage could solve a lot of this and
then my my prayer is that they would get
to a point that they in agreement and
realize okay he's not he's not going to
he's not going to do X Y and Z and now
as a team we have to work together and
if you guys get to that point Heather
that's where you have to say all right
we're in this together and what are we
going to do and that's right um but oh
and then it's on both of you to just
link arms and get out of it together yep
and that's what we pray for we don't
want this to split couples but this is
this is the stuff that causes divorce
and and and Mar marries right 100% if
another spouse doesn't want to take the
responsibility of the decisions they've
made they're probably not taking
responsibility in other parts of the
marriage too such a good point hard so
hard such a good point and such a good
reminder man it's uncomfortable and it
is not fun but have conversations with
that person that you're engaged to or
even that person that you're dating and
if you've just gotten married start
having these conversations you've got to
know the other person's philosophy on
money at the end of the day and not just
make assumptions and go oh they've got a
good job they probably have it together
or they don't seem like they have a lot
of debt like really digging deeper and
figuring out and just asking you know
even when you dream together Rachel like
I know there's times Sam and I will sit
together and think about oh it would be
cool to have a business like that one
day then take it a level deeper and go
well to what extremes would you go like
I would never take out money for a
business would you you know really ask
the questions find ways to bring money
into the conversation so you really
understand in a lot of different facets
what their views are on money because as
we see here it can really
be an issue long term such a tension
point so yeah it's a big um it's a big
relational MH uh wedge that's calleda so
yeah you're exactly right and I think
you know especially when you're dating
engag we get this question a lot of you
know when do I bring up the money when
do I all of it and you know we would
always encourage to be having hard
conversations about everything right and
and we've talked to people on the show
that have been dating for six years and
they don't they don't know anything
about the their partner's financial
situation and they think this or that
and and I remember being on the show
with you one time we're like what do
they talk about I know so so take this
stuff seriously you guys I'm like don't
like ask about their 401K on the first
date but that's a little extreme but
start you know understanding like to be
in the same value system with the person
you're going to link arms with and um
yeah but it's it's a hard one it reveals
a lot listen I say all the time if you
have babies together you can share a
bank account like that that needs to be
it and both people's opinions should
matter and sometimes it takes some time
in many many conversations and
counseling to get to that point but go
through that Journey this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys you know this but I'll say
it anyway college is freaking expensive
and student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000 so if you're in over your head
with private student loan debt don't
beat yourself up look we've all made
mistakes with money in the past what
matters is doing something about it now
so if you're in distress with private
student loans that's private not federal
student loans call why refi y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay to learn
more about this custom refinancing
option call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
this is the ramsy show I'm Jade warshaw
this is Rachel Cruz to my right and
we're taking your calls so give us a
call the number is
8825 5225 and we'll try to help you out
let's go straight to the phone lines
where we have Avery in Newport News
Virginia what's going on Avery hey Jaden
Rachel it's so great to talk to you I
can't wait to see you guys in May
awesome oh you're coming to The Total
Money Makeover weekend oh yeah
absolutely and I'm bringing a friend too
love it that's exciting so fun o love
that how can we help today all right so
here is the situation my mom always says
the strongest thing in the universe is
compound interest my brother always says
time in the market beats timing the
market every time let's go uh and I
thought I was smart enough to time a dip
I had about $21,000 worth in a Fidelity
mutual fund in my Roth IRA and I sold my
positions on it back in September I was
going off a bad hunch and have watched
the market rally by like at least 20%
since and I've calculated that I missed
out on about $4,000 worth of gross I'm
kicking myself I still contribute weekly
but that $21,000 is still sitting there
in the account feel like I've learned my
lesson but what do I do now should I buy
back in or should I wait for the rally
to end and maybe buying at a dip listen
I'm first I'm glad that you've learned
your lesson and I hope that it sticks um
do you have any
debt I have no debt okay do you have
three to six months of expenses saved
yes I do awesome listen I'm getting back
in today and from here on out I'm adding
15% of my gross income to it every
single
month okay today yeah how are you
feeling are are your armpits sweating
what's going on yeah I feel I mean I
feels like I don't know if I buy now I
feel like if you wait you're timing the
market again that means you haven't
learned your you haven't learned your
lesson Avery yes listen yeah because
Avery I think the I think the point the
point though is is that all of this is
longterm right so whether you get in
today whe you get in in 30 days whatever
it is the earlier you get in and you
ride this out again long term we're
talking decades here um that's what's
important so
$4,000 at the end of you know when
you're you know 65 it's gonna be a drop
in the bucket because how old are you
now I'm 25 yeah so like all of the I
mean it is there if you time it if if
Avery of February of 24 is different
than Avery in July of 24 I mean like you
know if you wait 6 months or whatever
it's not absolutely the end of the world
but I think it's more about the
principle behind this right the idea is
that I can't time the market it's an
election year we have no clue what's
going to happen and so if anything I'm
like yeah the lesson is I'm not going to
try try to time the market the lesson is
I want to invest long term that's what
I'm doing so to practice on the
principle of the idea is to say yeah I'm
at a position to start investing put my
money in the market
yeah okay and so even if I buy in today
and then it goes down like I feel like
I'm going to kick myself again Aver
you're not going to worry about it until
you're 65 how old are you 24 25 listen
think about it okay if you I think
you're focusing and Rachel tried to lay
it out for you and I think she did a
beautiful job but let me take a swing at
it I think you're so focused in whatever
rate of return that you're hoping to get
immediately or in the next couple of
months but if you look at it the the
like I don't know if you're new to the
show but we talk all the time about oh
you can get you know if even if you just
invest in an S&P 500 account you're
still going to look at about 10% over
time everything is overtime and if
you're pulling it out every month or
every other month or when you think the
market is dipping you're not allowing
for the rebound that always happens on
the other end of that and you can look
over the the the last 20 years even and
you can just see listen the annualized
rate of return has been upwards of 10%
and that's what you can count on that's
why we suggest what we suggest and
that's why everybody invests in these
accounts in order to have their
retirement Avery I say this in the most
loving big sister way that I can you are
going to be your worst enemy okay you're
going to be the person that's going to
be going on CNBC and watching the the
the ticker at the bottom and saying oh
gosh oh gosh Avery you got you have to
you have to put the money in and you got
to forget about it that's what this is
this part of investing is that it is
long-term retirement type mentality and
and it's going to take some it's going
to take some uh restraint from you and
your personality cuz already I'm trying
to talk you off the ledge and your
money's not even in the market but you
know what Avery need averly Avery is who
really needs a smart Vestor Pro because
one of the things that they will help
you do is not freak out talk you off
ledge Yes yes exactly yeah so it is one
of those things Avery you I mean I I I
never really I mean I watched the market
for this job so so we know what's going
on in the economy but from a personal
standpoint I'm like and it kind of sucks
for me Avery from a personally because
I'm like I'm such a spender and when we
fund our 401ks and roths and all the
things that we're supposed to do cuz
we're smart and we're wise and we
actually do it Jade even though it kind
of makes me like cuz it feels like a
black hole and I'm like this money is
leaving we're we could be going on a
great vacation this summer that so it
does kind of feel like man my money's
just leaving and I'm never going to see
it again but you have to have the you
you have to know that a 65-year-old
Avery is is going to want to live a
great life and and you're going to have
a plenty of money to do that Avery if
you start investing now and not try to
time every little thing because when
you're in that little situation that's
the principle you live by you're you're
not going to win long term because you
have to have a long-term mentality yeah
you can't do the I feel like he's trying
to find a way to maybe make this thing
happen faster and get rich quick and I'm
like listen it it doesn't work that way
and if it does I feel like it's a fluke
and then everybody tries to figure out
what it was that they did it's like
listen just understand it was just
something that happened in a moment so o
I hope that helps let's take another
call let's go to Haley in Philadelphia
all right Haley what's going on hey guys
thanks um for taking my call you're
welcome how
my question is I'm wondering if I should
um sell my car to pay off my student
loans or if I should keep my car paid
off tomorrow and follow the baby sets to
um pay off my student loans instead okay
well how much do you have saved and how
much is the car bringing if you sell it
so I so I have um $10,000 saved and the
car value on Kelly Blue Book is
15,000 okay um do you owe anything on
the car so
yeah I owe five okay 5,000 so
essentially you'd be and how much how
much is your student
loans um I have 17,000 in stent okay how
much do you make a
year I make 70 oh good no I would not
sell this car no you owe $5,000 throw
that throw 5,000 to the 10,000 have it
paid off today and it's gone and then
you have yeah $4,000 keep $1,000 in an
emergency fund take 4,000 throw it at um
yeah the student loans and gosh and you
got 13,000 left making 70,000 you're
yeah you'll be able to pay off these
student loans quick yeah I love it okay
I would I would not sell
it okay perfect and I'm right now I'm
putting 11% of my um take home pay into
my 401k so I'm assuming I should
probably stop that yes right pause that
yep exactly so that'll be more money
back in your paycheck to throw at the
step which is which is awesome yeah I
mean if you had like we talked to a girl
um two days ago me and George did she
had a SUV BMW she could sell it for like
70,000 I mean it was a pretty big like
chunk you know she owed some money on it
she could have paid it off with her Sal
all this stuff but I'm like but I mean
like it was a it was like it's a it was
a you know an asset that's like oh my
gosh you could sell it and make
something but no you yeah with with a
$115,000 car you owe five you make 70
you're in a great position just to sell
it and you have that $10,000 saved which
is awesome o that's great and I I mean
the reason why I wanted to sell my car
to begin with is because I live I live
in Philly so I don't and I work from
home so I'm literally using my car once
a week and that's only to like go see my
parents um so that was kind of my my
kind of thought but I mean it makes
sense too I mean it's I don't feel like
it's something that's on fire for you to
make that choice right away I'm with
Rachel if you if you still owed 15 on it
it might be a different discussion but
the fact that you only owe five and you
have the five in your possession and you
still have money to make decent Headway
on the student loan I feel like it's
something that after you pay off the car
and maybe
a year from now if you're like listen I
never use this car you might decide to
sell it but for now sticking with it
listen good job I'm happy for you you'll
be debt free at no time this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys ramsy Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
netsuite it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll company netw week can
scale with you and help you communicate
and plan better because you know your
day-to-day up and down and sideways but
accounting analytics and supply chain
are on another level so maybe you're
just not techsavvy that can be okay net
Suite will help at your speed and
whatever your situation more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netsuite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramy that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you are listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshot this is Rachel Cruz and let
me tell you something I'm hyped guys
because we have a great live event
coming up in the late spring actually
it's May 10th through 11th it's The
Total Money Makeover weekend and listen
I've been here for some really great
Live Events Rachel but I think this
might be the one that I'm most excited
about it's going to be all the person
alities it's a whole weekend here in
Nashville at our live event center up
there on a beautiful hill with a
beautiful view of Nashville in the
surrounding area and we're just giving
you a crash course on the baby steps how
to manage your money I love this event
because it's really for anybody
regardless of where you are in the baby
steps you could be on baby step one or
baby step seven yes and you're really
going to benefit from being at this
event it's like a rally Rachel I'm I'm
here for it and you know at Rams we've
done so many different types of events
like you said said M and we try to cover
you know some events we try to cover
your whole life and we try to you know
get do it all but it is fun to kind of
focus in on a subject like money which
Ramsay's you know it's what we talk
about most of the time here on the show
and so to have a whole weekend dedicated
to that and really have the time to walk
through uh principles and ideas and
motivation and fun George and I are
going to do a smart money happy hour
live broadcast uh the Friday before I
think I'm allowed to say that go ahead
and say it if you didn't yeah if I
wasn't supposed too sorry uh and yeah
there's just some really fun things
we're going to be doing and if you are a
fan of of the of the content on this
show and others you're going to love
this weekend it's it's a really fun
listen I'm excited I had a meeting
yesterday with one of our um folks on
staff who helps plan the content and I
told her one of my ideas it's out of the
box Rachel so J you're always good at
that it's going to be fun so early bird
tickets start at $99 but remember it's
for a limited time so go to ramseys
solutions.com events today because
because Rachel and I both know these
tickets sell out super fast and if you
want that early bird pricing you got to
do it today or like tomorrow this
weekend you just got paid so go on ahead
and do it it's $99 get that now at ramsy
solutions.com
events that's exciting man after that I
feel like we have to go to the phone
lines if you want to call in the numbers
8825 5225 and we'll try to get to your
call but in the meantime we have Madison
in Tampa Florida what's going on
Madison hi guys thanks for taking my
call um so I'm just in a predicament um
I just found out that I will be
terminated from my job that I've been at
for almost five years um as of July 31st
of this year sorry I'm so sorry what do
you
do um I'm currently a business Financial
administrator um for a sales and
marketing company okay um yeah uh I make
about
$43,000 a year okay at this job um so I
have six months to plan um we're not
officially terminated until July 31st
and at that time we will receive
Severance although I don't know how much
okay um um I keep going I was gonna say
I I don't currently have anything in
savings and I'm worried about what's
coming next yeah yeah so Madison the way
I would handle this you know when we um
talk to people who are paying off debt
and there's a big life
that they are aware of most of the time
it's a baby right they're they're
pregnant and we call it stor mode pause
the the debt snowball and just pilot
money and I would say the same would be
true if someone knows that they're going
to relocate and they know that they're
going to have some uh moving expenses
we'd say put some of that money aside
and for you thank God you have six
months um which is a gift to at least
know that they're not coming in and
they're like today's your last day
honestly um so for now I would I would
save you know as much as possible I
would be in that mode of saving saving
saving do you have a lot of
debt um so I have about $133,000 in debt
um the majority of it uh student loans
um I just recently got my accounting my
associates degree in accounting okay
okay so yeah so what I would do I would
be saving Madison and then I mean I
would start looking what meish and say
hey I'm gonna or even line up a job
sooner than that and just say I'm trying
to do it now would you leave the job I
always wonder about that they give you
six months I mean if you know if you
know it's happening in 6 months I don't
I I would not wait to I personally would
not wait to the wire um I don't I'll be
honest with you uh Madison I don't know
a ton about the financial admin space is
there a lot of jobs out there is it easy
to just kind of go and apply for
something and get it or do you feel like
you know that it could be a couple of
months to find something what do you
think have you looked or do you kind of
know the
landscape so I don't think there's much
as far as the admin side um but I do
have a part-time um currently with a
company called Primerica and I'm
currently getting license I just
recently got licensed for life insurance
and I'm currently trying to get licens
for Investments um so I've been trying
to build that and I am also wondering so
I'm about to receive my tax return that
time of year yeah um I'm going to
receive a nice chunk I have a
12-year-old three-year-old 2-year-old
and a one-year old oh we didn't get that
okay good okay so you have four kids
yeah yeah so um I'm you know I'm going
to receive about little over $10,000 for
my taxx return and I'm wondering what my
best steps are to that are you married
Madison um no I'm not I have a partner
um I do have a I have a boyfriend okay I
just didn't know if there was like a
dual income situation um here's the
thing yeah I'm the only I'm the I'm the
bread winner in my situation okay don't
stick what I don't want you to do is
stick around simply to get the severance
like thinking like I'm going to do this
thing up to the wire to get especially
an unknown amount that you're like
listen I don't even know how much it is
um I in this equation I care more about
um stability and taking care of the kids
so really lining up something or at
least listen start getting options it's
not to say that you have to take the
first job you apply for but start seeing
what's out there if I'm you I'm using
this as an opportunity to take a step up
find another position that's you know
within my field of knowledge and what I
love to do to possibly get a raise and
get a higher salary and really just look
at this I mean I know it sucks and it
hurts been there for 5 years um but like
Rachel said it's a gift that you've got
6 months and really think of this as the
stair step to the next best thing and
the next good thing for you and your
family and um before you get off here
let's let's connect her with some of the
Ken Coleman materials the assessment his
book uh proximity principle would be
great too yeah so Austin if we can give
those to her that's a great Point yeah
and and Madison I would be encouraged to
you know I mean it's not like you're
trying to replace
$143,000 position a $43,000 you can do
that you're smart you've done this and
and you've been with this company for 5
years so there is you know a part of you
that you want to leave well but I don't
know why my my heart kind of flipped on
this Jay but when I'm like oh you got
four kids all right we're a single mom
we got to provide now you have to do
what's best for Madison and and I think
you can leave well and respectfully but
I would be looking for another job
because you got to pay your bills and so
and if you find it and you find a job
you love and they need a sooner start
date I would just tell the company you
know I would give plenty of notice do it
respectfully but you have to take care
you have four kids to take care of so I
would I would do this faster you know
and again I hate to say if you're a
single person all that but you don't
have there there's not as much that's
right that's on you you could probably
have a level of flexibility to a degree
but when you have dependence in your
household you want to make sure that
that you're well covered so I would be
saving that tax return I would be saving
every penny you can um between now and
finding a new job but well let's talk
about that Rachel okay so when I was in
my day um when if you left a job it was
like listen give give two weeks notice
or more if you can is that still like
the running I think so is that still the
thing two weeks notice to me I feel like
that's a respectful right and the
company you know like here at Ramy if
someone gives her two weeks they usually
don't laugh they don't stay the whole
two weeks it's like hey let's wrap some
stuff up cuz once you're done you're
done um but if they're in a position of
because it sounds like layoffs so the so
the company's not in a good position so
if she does have a critical role I would
want to hand that responsibility off yes
to do it well before my area is is gone
or whatever the situation is um so
that'll never bite you in the butt it's
all you never want to burn Brides is
very appropriate I think yeah I think so
too I'm like listen if you can give more
if there's a way to do that I'm not mad
at less and I'm like or like or two days
or what you know me that's terrible or
to just walk in and be like I quit like
are you kidding listen you never know
one thing I've learned Rachel is you
never know who you'll run into on down
the line you know you get older cuz the
the world is small like it's big but
it's small and I have always been
shocked at the people who have like come
back around in my life or vice versa and
it's kind of funny cuz sometimes people
want things and I'm like I know how you
work and so with you before you know
yeah but Madison too and anyone out
there that has a big change like that I
think Jade you said something that was
like yes see this as an opportunity of
growth and Ken's book The Proximity
principle is really going to help you
find that next better thing right this
is a closed door to open something great
and we we want to believe that for you
Madison absolutely well thanks for
hanging out with us keep hanging out
with us we're going to take more of your
calls here from more of you guys coming
up
[Music]
[Applause]
next
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ram show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host for this
hour Jade horshaw joined by your other
host Rachel Cruz and we are taking your
calls for the next couple hours on your
life your money whatever it is that's
going on in your financial situation
we'd like to help you with that so give
us a call the number is
88255 225 and we'd be happy to uh give
our two cents all right let's go
straight to the phone lines we've got
Trevor TR in Tacoma Washington what's
going on
Trevor hey thanks for taking my call you
bet yeah yes um had a question me and my
wife have been paying off debt for the
past seven years slowly but we have two
items left which is our house and my
student debt okay last last year I
started uh investing through uh Fidelity
and within six months I've uh put in
about $110,000 okay pretty much from
side hustles okay and my student debt is
around that same amount $10,000 it's the
last Deb I have I feel like I know the
answer but I'm wondering if I should
pull that and pay off the student debt I
haven't made really any money in the
stock market only being in there for six
months is it just a brokerage account or
is it a retirement account I have two uh
I maxed out last year and then I've
started this year so in the Roth I have
about 7500 and in a just normal
brokerage it's about
1,800 um I would not touch the Roth It's
retirement and I do not want you to
start the habit of if I need money I
pull it out of my retirement now if you
had single stocks laying around listen
what's in The Brokerage is technically
up for grabs it's not a whole lot of
money but it's some money um yeah what I
really want to hammer home though is the
idea of just stay the course like it
sounds like you understood it sounds
like you understood that the plan is for
you to pause retirement until you finish
paying off debt but it sounds like and I
relate to this because when you said
seven years everything in my body went I
know about that because it took my
husband and I seven and a half years and
it sounds like you kind of got a little
bit weary and maybe felt like you were
getting behind and so maybe you started
investing
and I just want to encourage you from
this point on listen I would stop
investing and finish paying off this
debt like I said don't touch your
retirement what you've put in there
already if you want to pull what's in
The Brokerage you can like there's no
penalty on that other than maybe a
little bit of tax on it but um how much
do you guys make a year
Trevor um we're a single uh single home
uh income I I stay at home and
homeschool two kids and she makes about
70 70,000 and um so you guys have been
paying off debt for seven years what was
the you guys paid off and how much was
it it was actually my side we got
married a few years ago and it was all
my side that and it
was oh jeez the whole story of me being
in the military
overseas my other significant other not
paying off debt and it just stacked up
racked up and it was horrible gotcha
gotcha okay talking about credit cards
repossessed cars so you guys have been
through it Trevor I mean to Jade's point
like seven years but but honestly um so
I get the you know there's a weariness
there where you're just like oh my gosh
but yeah but what you've done though so
far which is one of the biggest
obstacles for people is to change what
you believe about money right there was
one set of beliefs that you had overseas
in the military that got you you know
those choices created an outcome that
you said I don't like this outcome so
you have been working your way right out
of this so I think that one of the
biggest again hurdles you've overcome
that is hey I'm going to look at money
differently but then you get into the
details into kind of the nitpicky stuff
like we are here at Ramsay where we're
like pause retirement like there's
certain things you do for a reason this
isn't just for the heck of it it's it's
because of what we've seen over time and
this last bit Trevor I mean this is like
I know I hate to even like relate it to
this but I just watched some videos on
Instagram real and there was a it was
the cars are paid off now is there a way
I can do both maybe make a higher
payment on my student debt no I think
you just I think you just pause it
you're going to be okay for a year yeah
for a year and and and you guys make
70,000 and I would even Trevor I like if
there's anything like at night that you
can go do if you can make a side gig of
you know with a th000 bucks a month like
that's going to add to this I mean
anything this is where my money came
from with side gigs like put into this
what about the do do you have anything
that you guys from just a lifestyle
standpoint that you can cut oh we've
been we've been cut in the past two
month subscriptions okay good good so
you're kind of back in it it's that it's
that fuel but it's almost like you're
limping a little bit to that finish line
and I want you to Sprint like I just
want you I want you to get there and
you're going to be okay if it pauses for
a year how old are you guys uh 33 oh
yeah you guys are fine Jade's got yeah
Jade give us I love walking you through
this okay you said um you're investing a
little bit now what percentage are you
investing how much a month again it's
not from our actual account it's from me
doing side hust
around a th a month okay you're
investing a th a month which means
obviously when you have this debt clear
you'll have that and more to invest
right so let's just pretend that you
said right now there's 75 in your Roth
I'll just put it at 5,000 just to be I'm
I'm going to make this like so foolproof
and let's say that every month you do an
additional $1,000 every single month
this is after you're out of debt this is
after you're out of debt and this is I'm
going to do like a super conservative
rate of return I'm going to say 8% just
for all the hater AIDS out there to just
calm down and let's say you retire at 33
right let's see how much money that
would be for you oh shoot no not retire
at 33 he has 33 oh he has he's I'm
saying for 33 years for 3 years in 30
years okay I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah yeah
wait Rachel keep the conversation going
cuz my computer's being yeah yeah so
he's 33 and let's say in 30 years you
decide that yeah I'm going to retire at
63 64
uh the beautiful thing is that you'll
see what the decisions you've already
made with the Roth which again would not
um completely agree with because you
still have debt but the proof is is that
even if you waited one more year didn't
contribute anything to Investments or
retirement paid off debt went back to
investing in retirement and put money
away in 30 33 years dude $1.5 million in
years and just pause this year off
you're still G my point is you're still
going to be just fine sorry for the
delay my computer was not doing what I
wanted it to do but that's starting at
$7,000 which you said you have 75 in
your Roth right now that's a 30-year
term you're you're in your 30s now
you're going to invest you're going to
you know retire in your 60s it's a very
conservative rate of return that I put
in here you're going to do better than
that rate of return I'm just letting you
know and this is 1,000 bucks a month
like come on now and then 15% of your
income to you with that 70,000 I would
push you guys to say yeah instead of
that going you know to debt that's going
to be now going to investing as well and
this is assuming nothing changes like
you're going to earn more money you're
going to have more opportunities like I
just want you to see worst case scenario
is $1.5 million come on Rachel Cruz oh
my goodness I'm so excited I feel like
people need to do this more people need
to run out the numbers and stop letting
it Circle above their head and cause
them fear that's out there it's like
you're over here getting a stomach ulcer
cuz you're like I'm getting too old and
I used to feel that way my husband and I
didn't start investing until our mid-30s
and now I see like we're going to be
just fine and you're going to be just
fine too work the plan as planned it
works every time this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsy show and
by the way thank you for listening to
the Ramsey Show um we're just so
grateful that that each and every day
you guys choose to log in or go on to
YouTube or go to your podcaster and pick
our show to listen to like that's great
we're here because of you all and uh we
just want to encourage you to keep doing
that keep liking keep subscribing and
really keep keep sharing it with people
that you think will enjoy the content
that we give to you guys every single
day um it doesn't cost you anything and
it really is beneficial for us and for
the people around you because they get
this wonderful resource but it also
helps us because it just helps the
algorithm favor us a little bit more
above some of the other things that are
out there so if you like this tell other
folks about it you know they might have
their crime podcast that they like but
like tell them about the ramsy show it's
a me it's
listen these crime podcast I don't
Rachel I don't get it but I'll send you
one I don't know if I can watch it I
feel like no a listening you listen
listen okay you don't yeah there's
nothing scary you see he just listen
ready I got I got you something Rachel
Cruz loves her a prime podcast Jade
warshaw your other host is fearful of
them but you know listen as long as
we're part of your your daily routine
and you listen to a little bit of the
ramsy show then go listen to a little
bit of your other
podcast so so funny well anyway my point
was to tell you that we appreciate you
and keep doing what you do we're going
to go to the phone lines where there's
Tony and Rochester New York what's going
on
Tony hi hey um so um I'm calling because
uh I I am quite a bit in debt um it's
gotten to a point where after I pay my
bills and subscriptions and things that
I got going on um it's the the amount of
credit card that I got is pretty much
takes over the rest of the paycheck and
um we're trying to manage it um I'm
looking at options I consider you know
sold a car considering maybe selling a
house a house do you have more than one
no the the house the house the house
okay yep selling the house um and uh
maybe using that to bring them down I
owe I I make about a 100,000 a year and
uh is that including your wife I about
what's that is the 100,000 including
your wife no it's just me just you does
she work outside the house well that
that's the our household I'm she's she's
she at home and um I'm the one that's
working outside how much credit card
debt do you guys have we got about 126
126,000 in credit card debt yeah and
Tony so yeah no you it's okay I I can
hear it in your voice Tony I mean it's
um that's hard that's really hard what
caused what was the the reason for
that well um I was out of work for for a
year trying to figure out different
things I attempted uh some things on my
own as well I weren't wasn't able to
make enough uh to to get us uh out of
you know
to be able to sustain us for a long time
start getting debt start getting credit
cards to be able to manage the uh you
know until I finally got a job and then
it's grown because once once I guess
there's a point of you have enough debt
the payment get it to get you to a point
where you can't
make it's it's what's left is not enough
so you you got to continue getting more
and debt more and more and more and we
haven't been able to manage reducing the
expenditures enough
yeah to um so how long have you been in
this in this job that you're in now how
long has it been about about about a
year okay so when did you decide when
was the point for you that you were like
I I got to do something different this
isn't this isn't working well I'm
looking at the numbers I mean few years
ago year well for a while we've been
wanting to do something but it's uh it's
become quite urgent now so we're trying
to figure out how much are you paying
every month how much are you paying
every month towards these credit cards
probably 1,500 a little more
1,500 three 3,500 oh 3,500 okay and is
that minimum payments that's the minimum
payments wow yeah and you mentioned a
car um is it tell me about the car
situation so we had two cars um one of
them I ended up having to spend quite a
bit in repairs and things like that and
I said well you know what um I got it
really nice but um I didn't want to
continue and and so I have another car
that's uh newer and it's in good shape I
I I don't I mean I I own loans on them
so um can I sorry just to clarify one
car right now at this point so there's
one car the the car that you said you
didn't want to you know continue with
what did you do with it do you still own
it does it just need the repairs sold it
you sold it sold it okay so now you're a
onec car family there's a one car family
for now yeah okay and the car that you
have what do you on it and what's it
worth it's it's uh I owe about 30,000 on
it it's probably worth the same amount
maybe a little more it's fairly newer so
it's kind of okay the loan is a little
older what the that car is worth so if I
were to sell it don't know that I'll get
my money back yeah you'd be underwater
in it um and there's no you have no
savings I'm assuming nothing saved
anywhere not well just a little bit and
I and one very little okay that's off
limits what I want to ask about um sorry
I'm gonna pry like I'm putting my
crowbar in and I'm prying out um your
wife's a stay at- home
mom yeah how many kid onine too she's
she's hearing hearing us hey girl
hi um hi hi hey so you're staying at
home you're doing you know you're doing
some heavy lifting um how many kids are
you watching and and taking care of
three three and what's their
ages we're uh already the U our oldest
one is
11 Andrea is eight and the the youngest
one is six okay so when I'm listening to
that I'm hearing school-aged kids which
is great because that daycare you know
Bill is not a thing so my question is
and you know I'm I'm I'm going around
this delicately but I think there's room
that you can work as well because right
now the most money that you can bring in
is what's going to break this
cycle yes yes yes I'm just trying to to
make smart choices uh like I was telling
him it's just difficult to to sit down
sorry and like search you know like a
search for a job that uh is prudent in
terms of uh knowing the the hours
minimum per hour and yeah just with one
car right now we uh are managing so he
takes the car for the most part right
now or or if not the
bus it it is a bit difficult but yeah
that that is my main goal well I always
say get I always say get a job until you
get the job cuz right now literally
anything you do is going to help you
guys out yeah if you drop the kids off
and go work at a bakery you know for you
know whatever it is like go yeah doing
something because um and what's your
name can I ask we have Tony
and
and okay yeah um it's not that I haven't
tried I I've actually sure sure to come
up like with uh on the side job like
staging uh because here's the deal you
guys I I I know Tony had mentioned or at
least it's here on our screen um one of
your biggest questions was debt
consolidation and here's what here's
what I want so so here's the deal you
guys what's going to fix this issue is
you guys it's not rearranging this
credit card debt and trying to find a
lower interest rate that's not your
problem the problem is is that you guys
lived a cycle with your money that got
you in this problem and in this mess but
the beautiful thing is yes you were the
ones that got yourselves in this mess
but you're the ones that's going to get
yourselves out of it okay and so listen
to each other because this is the stress
point because you're starting to make
that turn of saying we're going to do
something differently she's looking for
a job you've sold a car I mean you guys
are feeling this tension you're starting
to make these choices you're getting in
the right direction so stay on the same
team because Tony's not feeling great
about himself and when I heard you when
when you I heard your voice immediately
Tony I thought he's caring so much
there's a lot of Shame yes there's a lot
of guilt that you feel Tony like this
was my responsibility I tried taking
care of my family and this is what I got
us in she is supportive she sounds
wonderful you she's wantan to help but
but you guys together you have to work
as a team and stay on the line cuz
Austin's going to pick up and we're
going to give you Financial Peace
University and every dollar premium
which is our budgeting app and you guys
sit down together go through these
lessons learn the basics because debt
consolidation that's not going to be
your answer not the option you are your
answer you guys can do this we take
these calls every day and hear people
that do their debt free screams I mean
Jade is a living testimony of this of
you guys can do this it's going to take
a long time it's a lot of sacrifice but
it is possible so I'm so glad you guys
called today and we we wish you nothing
but the best you guys can do
this
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100% %
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
40% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
hey you're listening to the ramsy show
I'm Jade warshaw this is Rachel Cruz to
my right and we're taking calls about
your life and your money just came off
of a call and you know honestly we get
calls all the time of people you know
they're in a a hard financial situation
and you know we're asking questions and
in around to kind of figure out what's
the core of the problem where the
problem come from how can we go about a
life that we're not repeating those
mistakes again and you kind of do have
to dig in and each individual kind of
has to go back and do their own digging
so that they're figuring out what
happened here like it's good to want to
solve a problem but you also have to go
back and go okay but what happened like
what caused me to to act in that way
what did I do that caused this to kind
of spin out um and we try to help you
guys with that a little bit and some of
that is personal work but one of the the
themes that I notice Rachel is and I get
this like I this is not me pointing a
finger this is just I think a human
nature thing that we have to guard
against which is you know everybody has
work in the words of kin kin Coleman
that they were created to to do and
everybody wants to find the work that
they're created to do and the thing that
gives them life and the thing that gives
them energy and I'm all for that you
know you want to be excited to go to
work and feel like it's time well spent
um but I do find that a lot of times we
enter into seasons of life that we are
doing work that we don't love and it's
not the job and it's not right the one
that we were hoping for and I you'll
hear me say it time and time again do a
job until you get the job and so in the
spirit of what I think is just a
consistent thread that we see throughout
and even that I face throughout times in
my life is five reasons to get any job
to go just to get any job all right so
number one some money is better than no
money that's right right some money
coming in is better than no money when
Co hit uh we were in the cruise industry
and ain't nobody going on cruises and
the live entertainment industry and
wasn't nobody going to a live event so I
had to get a job and my husband had to
get a job I had to get a job that I did
not like that to be honest I was over
fully fully fully overqualified for but
we want to just burn savings so it's
like bring in some money like we we're
debt free we have hardly any expenses
any money that we bring in is going to
be great so we did that and it didn't
feel good and let me just say I don't
necessarily believe that work is beneath
people but in some days it felt like it
was beneath me like let's just be honest
about that somebody needs to say it you
you know some of you feel like listen I
I don't I should I shouldn't be working
at McDonald's okay I get that you feel
that way but you don't have any money so
go work at McDonald's all right and
listen just be happy that McDonald's is
open cuz back in the day in Co it wasn't
even open so anyway um some money is
better than no money Rachel the next one
I have here is your spouse needs to see
who you
are and if you're a husband or a wife
and you're facing a very hard time in
your marriage go get a job because when
they see you at home and you're not
working and they feel like they're
taking on the burden of that you can
help take some of that off
so go get a job and then that might
encourage your spouse to go get a job
like that is good your spouse will feel
like I remember when I was a kid one
like my dad he just was always working
and I was like one thing about my dad is
like this man is going to work like and
it just it builds a sense of security in
your kids and in your family go get a
job and and no one's going to be going
well but but my dad only works here no
one is saying that they're going listen
my dad goes out and works hard every day
that's right go get a job all right uh
number three um you'll learn what you
like and what you don't like yes by
testing out all different things yeah
listen I don't like food service I don't
like call center um I don't really like
working with animals even though I like
animals um yeah I like cooking I don't
like making wedding cakes I've done it
before it's a lot of work like I can
tell you Rachel Cruz the things that
Jade does not like
doing okay um and I now I know the
situations that I do enjo enjoy working
in so you'll learn what you like you'll
learn what you don't like uh number four
you'll be productive yes and there's
just something to be said for all right
I'm getting up and leaving and doing
something yeah or not leaving but
staying at home and being on your
computer doing something something
you're getting out of your bed even if
you're putting on sweatpants and going
up and putting your little headpiece on
and doing your call center job I'm
almost talking about it like I know
it okay and then finally it will build
confidence in you because when you go
the longer you go without a job the more
you wonder if you'll ever be able to get
a job so to just go from one job to
another says listen I've got some
confidence like I can say when I go to
my next interview I can say that I'm
currently working or I can say here's
the experience that I've had yeah yeah
or at least feel it on the inside that's
right so there you have it five five
reasons to take any job before you get
the job and that was free ladies and
gentlemen right from Jade warshaw that's
amazing Jade I mean seriously because I
do think that there is this feeling and
especially if you've been in a certain
industry or you kind of have your line
of sight of like this is what I do and
you get laid off or you or you know
you're in a bad situation you quit
whatever the whatever the reason is yeah
and you still have that kind of narrow
focus of this and to your point when
when bills have to be paid open those
Horizons and go just do something yes
yeah and you know one door leads to
another and you never know you might be
uh taking someone's Burger order and you
meet some you know the person taking the
order they they have a situation that
they tell you about and it leads to the
next thing you just you never ever know
what's behind a door so don't don't
count it out and think that you're above
it or think that it's just keep going
anyway I digressed I got to take a deep
breath I love it we got to go to Brenda
in Washington DC sorry Brenda that you
have to come after that but what's going
on in your
world hi so um me and my husband are
looking to buy a house uh we want to
know if we're even there yet and if we
are what steps financially we should
take to get there as far as um pausing
our investments continuing to invest or
um yeah what we should do okay um well
what we what we look at Brenda is a
series of steps that we want completed
before you go and purchase your first
home so uh are you how much debt do you
guys
have um we have about I think 12,000
total for our cars and that's it and
that's it okay perfect and do you guys
have any money
saved we have about 55,000 in savings
okay that's great how much you guys make
a
year um combined we have make around 220
before taxes I don't know what it is
after to be honest yeah okay perfect
that's a great income um okay so if I
were you Brenda I would pay off your
cars today with the money that you guys
have saved
in that $55,000 account um and then the
remaining I would look to see how much
your expenses are a month because what
we say is after you pay off all your
Consumer Debt look to get a three to six
months of expenses saved in a fully
funded emergency fund and you can put
that you know that money in a high yield
savings or a money market um and for you
guys you know you may want to put some
more toward savings um once the car once
you pay off the cars or maybe that's
enough for you guys but I want you guys
to look at your own budget and figure
out okay if we need probably three
months you guys have
kids no we do have a kid on the way
that's part of our oh okay we want to
buy a house too that's so great well
congratulations when are you due yeah
thank you um September in September okay
that's awesome um so yeah so I I
wouldn't I wouldn't push the timeline of
the home with or without the baby okay
so meaning like I wouldn't feel like oh
my gosh I have to get in before the baby
or what I wouldn't let the baby's
timeline dictate your house timeline I
want your money to dictate the house
timeline so again I want that fully
funded emergency fund and honestly
Brenda with the baby on the way you know
starting to look for a home I would I
would feel comfortable around that 5 to
six month Mark um for an emergency fund
and just making sure you guys have
plenty of cash set aside and then you
want to start saving up for your down
payment and I would say to put at least
5% down and make sure your payment is no
more than 25% of of your take-home pay
so when you run those numbers you guys
can kind of look now you're in you're in
the DC area so you're in an
expensive part of the country real
estate wise so your expectations and our
formula you know we get knocked on it
sometimes it is more on the conservative
side but I don't want this house to be
the thing that stresses you guys out so
it may take maybe another year or two or
depending on you know what kind of house
you guys are looking at um to really
kind of slow down and say yep let's get
in a good position have a good down
payment
and making sure that it's a reasonable
payment within our income to make sure
to pull the trigger so I hope that's
helpful Brenda and if you go to Ramsey
solutions.com we have tons of uh
articles and free content on home
purchasing so make sure to check that
[Music]
out
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show hey
by the way a couple of days ago we did a
c Q Anda after the ramsy show all on
budgeting and it was it was really cool
it was live it was George and I here in
the studio it's still on the YouTube
page if you want to go and check that
out if you have any questions about our
budgeting app every dollar which is the
best budgeting app in the world we did a
live Q&A where we had every dollar
pulled up on the screen uh George and I
were just kind of little characters in
the corner so you could really see how
the budgeting app works and we answered
Rachel gosh probably eight or 10
questions in depth and I mean it's
questions that most of you have all the
time how do I do syncing funds what do I
do if I get paid four times a week do I
do my budget by week or how do I do it
we answered All Those Questions we
talked about um gosh paying off debt so
many just everyday questions so if
that's something you're interested in
find it on our YouTube page I'm sure
they'll pull it up at some point or
maybe even after this segment so stay
tuned for that it's so valuable there it
is it was really really cool I think
like over gosh the numbers on it were
crazy I'm not gonna sit here and try to
quote it but my point is go watch it
because it was super duper valuable and
I'm sure that we'll do that again I
don't know when but it was super
valuable so go in there every dollar
again such a great budgeting tool but
like let's be honest there's sometimes
questions that you have and things that
you want to know about it and so we're
here to answer those questions as well
as questions about your life and your
money which we're going to do the
numberers 8825 5225 we're here to help
and let's go to Jerry and Phoenix
Arizona what's going on Jerry how you
doing thanks for taking my call you're
welcome how can we help my my question
is I'm 66 my wife is 71 she's been
diagnosed and had um dementia for three
years I'm s getting close to having to
go into than go into a long-term care
facility I've done the baby steps I have
like 5,000 in emergency fund and 20,000
in savings and investing my house is
paid for but my question is should I
sell my house to pay for her long-term
care which I can't afford on my
income how much does the long-term care
how much is it costing you like what's
the cost per month per year cost per
month for long-term care is about 7,000
a month and I take home only 5,000 with
my retirements
okay and are you retired Jerry then yes
I'm retired military disability and
Social Security okay okay
so tell us more about your your home
situation okay I own my home it's worth
about
700,000 I could sell the house here and
move into a smaller house for like
400,000 and would leave me about
250,000 and I could use that to pay
monthly on longterm care memory care
that would only last for maybe two years
or three years assuming it's not
invested what's at the house no the
250,000 are you just thinking of it as a
lump sum as it is Cash yeah I would have
to yeah it would just be My Equity out
of the house after I sold it and tell me
again sorry I was kind of writing down
some things tell me again what you have
in retirement as it stands okay military
retirement military disability Social
Security and my wife social security and
it adds up to
about 48 4,800 a month but what are the
nest eggs is there neest EG anywhere in
there um I got uh 20,000 in the savings
account and 5,000 in another savings
account from my emergency fund
okay let me think try to get you know we
trying to get everything right and house
paid off and yeah getting there but then
this happens yes I'm so sorry and Jerry
I mean I'm assuming because you called
and asked the specific question I mean
so she she will need to be in
a yeah to a point where I'm not going to
be able to take care of her you know my
age and I'm doing full-time car taking
for her right now but I I'm just trying
to look into the future I know it's not
going to last forever yeah I know oh I'm
so sorry have you um have you looked at
other options at other whether it's you
know homes or facilities or even in in
home care at
all um yeah I have looked in it it's
it's a little bit cheaper but not not
very much still going to be about 5,000
okay more than I more than I take home
so yeah in this case though a 2,000
difference is a big difference from
5,000 to 7,000 so it is something to
consider okay yeah I thought about that
because the house that I have now well
I'd have to sell this house that's how
that's the only thing I could think of
to be able to have money to do
anything yeah I mean I do think so there
yeah it's it is it's a large asset um
it's paid off which is just
incredible and I think it is you know
that like you know you need money for
her right and so you do have um a stream
of income in a sense with this I mean
not income but you have the ability to
get some cash if you do sell um this
home um what would it look like you you
ran one scenario where you sell this
$700,000 home you take $ 250 you invest
it well and you're pulling off of it for
a number of years to only fund it for so
long but that's with you buying a three
or $400,000 house is there any situation
it's just going to be you in the home um
possibly depending on which route you go
is there is there a a route where you
buy something far less expensive like a
condo as opposed to a full-size house
even even though it would be downsizing
but something even smaller where you've
got a larger nest egg that you can
invest in draw off for a longer period
of time M that's that's always an option
I know in the Phoenix area even
condos getting up there
pricewise yeah for sure yeah
um yeah I mean Jerry I'm so I'm so sorry
um I mean I probably would yeah I would
look to to probably sell and and I think
you do have to map out um because what I
don't want to happen is you sell this
paid off asset and um there's nothing
left for you there's nothing left for
you or you end up running out and then
you have to go to another option right
um and so um yeah I would I would run
the numbers pretty tightly I probably
wouldn't rush into buying something new
right now for you um as you go and I
would look at other options for um care
care as well um I mean obviously we want
the best for our loved ones for sure but
that industry can vary so so much and
you guys obviously you don't have she
doesn't have long-term care insurance or
I mean anything right okay something I
never planned for I wish I would have no
I know I know well and and it she's so
young you know it's just um I'm so sorry
would you you you would invest the money
if you sold the house and then tried
take the money out of the Investments or
how would that work yeah I I probably
would try to take away as big a chunk as
possible that's why I was saying is
there a way that you can do a situation
where you're taking the majority of the
sale of this and investing it because
then what you're drawing off of it is
much less and you would only draw off
what you needed to fund this since
you're living since you already have
some income of course coming in from all
of your different retirement options you
wouldn't have to pull much I mean we're
talking about you said you bring in
5,000 this is an additional 7 to 5,000
so it' be you coming up with a a a
retirement option where it allows you to
pull off 5,000 and you're dwindling that
Nest Egg far slower than if it was a
$250,000 Nest like going in with 6 or
700,000 is a lot different than going in
with
250,000 so to Rachel's point like I hate
the idea of you being a homeowner and
then you not being a homeowner anymore
but I would love if you worked with a
professional to see what your options
are because a I want you to be able to
take care of her but B you're not
getting any younger either and so
there's got to be a situation where
you're covered as well and that'll just
at the very least having your options
will really just help give you peace
about okay this this is this is what I
know I can do here are my options it's
not floating around in my head and being
able to choose between a couple of
things on paper as opposed to just
thinking all right this is my only
choice I can only do y x that's right
that's right right so that that makes
sense talk to prob an investor yeah we
have smartvestor Pros you can hop on um
Ramsey solutions.com and check out our
our smartvestor pros and they're going
to help you really see okay here's what
we can do and they're going to shoot you
straight and tell you what your options
are and again that's going to help give
you a very clear picture of what your
choices are moving forward and how to
stretch this money out as long as
possible Jerry right I mean I think
that's that's going to be the goal to
make her comfortable to make you feel
good about the situation but how can you
do that while balancing you have a chunk
of money and how can we how can we get
that to go as far as possible yeah tough
stuff but you know there are options and
the more knowledge is power that's what
I was trying to get to at the end of the
day knowledge is power so go out there
and see how those smart vestors can help
you this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jak oraw
joined by your other host for the day
Rachel Cruz taking your calls all
afternoon long your life your money we
want to hear about it the number is8 825
5225 and we will get into it so you know
come ready cuz we're going to give you
our thoughts and our advice on it all
right so let's go to the phone lines
where there's Vanessa in Dallas Texas
waiting what's going on
Vanessa hi ladies thank you so much for
your time today no problem absolutely
how glad you're hear I'm so glad it's
the two of you because I really really
want your opinion I just enged two weeks
ago very excited
congratulations thank you so much we
don't have a date yet um we both rent
separately we're both completely out of
debt no secret credit cards nothing like
that um and I was just curious what
should we prioritize first I'm really
I'm one of those soon to be Brides where
I care more about getting into a home
rather than a very large expensive
wedding and I just I feel like I'm
suffering from paralysis as the analysis
and I don't really know where to go from
here okay good question oh my gosh so
for you guys the wedding is it um is it
you guys paying for it you and your
fiance yes just us okay and how much you
guys make a year um we both make 65 resp
respectively so all together 130 130 we
haven't combined any finances yet yes oh
you're you're goodess is like I swear
we're doing this why I know I love it um
okay do you guys have money saved what
would be the money saved to that if you
were to combine savings not like you're
going to but if you were what would that
be at this point we both have a a fully
funded six-month emergency fund and that
is it like we we paid off all of our
debt saved up baby step three all of
that and then he popped the question so
we're really like we're we're basically
starting from um like baby step 3B
wedding fund so you both have a
six-month emergency fund separately
correct awesome okay so how how how much
is in how much is in yours how much is
in his mine is so since we make the same
amount of money um like it's right in
the neighborhood of about $20,000 each
of you has okay correct uh okay that's
great yep and I would I would leave that
alone um I would keep that as is and um
okay what is his take is he more is he
more on the house side or is he at all
have any I don't know I feel like dudes
don't really care about the wedding as
much usually stereotypically
yeah I would think so he's kind of torn
as well because um he was raised
Catholic so his his his family's um
approach to everything is like try to
get married in the church which is I
know is around like 10 to
15,000 um but if it I mean at the end of
the day we're both sort of like what if
we just went down to the courthouse and
could be done with it then when sort of
when you said that like are you saying
that the church is more expensive than
like another venue cuz I always feel
like the church route is less expensive
than like a ballroom
right so the church comes with a lot of
like prerequisites that you have to go
through like marriage counseling which
is wonderful um and like things like
that um and I think it just sort of as
like all encapsulated is about 10 to
$5,000 like we would be able to do it
probably for that much money okay but
you guys don't want to do that
necessarily not necessarily okay and you
don't have to yeah I mean I I would lean
on what you guys want and it sounds like
Vanessa unless I'm mistaken that you
both lean to like hey let's I mean it's
I mean you could do a lope you could go
a step up from alope get the license go
have a great party treat like an
engagement party yeah and have a great
reception um at some date you know later
in the future um but it sounds like your
priority is because of how I I can tell
how focused you guys are um is really
looking towards the future and looking
at like hey what's going to last us
longer and saving up more for a down
payment on a home is quote unquote
technically a better Financial
investment I won't necessarily say
emotionally and all the things but like
I do think whatever you choose you have
to make it a memory like you have to yes
do something that makes it like special
like if you say okay we're just going to
go down to the courthouse right now in
your life you're really um focusing on
the financial thing but there might be a
point later on where you see something
or something got dress I wish had done a
couple of things yes there is part of
that that I think that she should
include or you know that you should
include Vanessa even though even if you
choose to go like the the do the least
route right like still have a beautiful
dress still do something that's going to
create a me a memory in your mind where
later on you will look back and not feel
like you missed out because you still
did something and it is interesting
because these types of situations and
you could probably put vacation in this
realm that I'm talking about or other
things it is is so personality driven I
had a cousin and they went to Washington
literally went to the top of a mountain
had a pastor do it and they were done
that's cool that's all because that was
like their thing and they're like that's
all we want we don't need a bunch of
people around we're good um you know and
then you know for me I'm like I love I
love a good party and I love dressing I
love all the things so I'm like I would
tend to lean which I did I I enjoyed my
wedding and I loved it um you know but
all that to say your person it and what
you guys want and what you guys value is
going to drive this and so maybe Vanessa
it be a fun exercise to write down maybe
three things for you in the wedding
category that you would genuinely love
to to have and maybe that's you know
maybe that's the dress or maybe that's a
a really good idea the idea of like what
three things are important to you what
three things are important to me and
like see what we meet in the middle and
you guys may yeah be be very similar in
it and we I mean we've talked to so
people on the show and they do it so so
inexpensively have a great time and then
they they ride off in the sunset and and
you know do it and then we know some
people too that are like no this is an
important day for us we really want to
take the most of it and we're going to
save put more money here and we'll worry
about the house in two to three years
you know so I don't think there's a
right or wrong honestly I think going
into debt yeah or making decisions like
that I think are will put you guys back
but I really think Vana lean into what
you guys both want not what everyone
else around you is saying so true and
listen there's two like thinking of
towards the future there's two ways to
think of this number one I Rachel I
think in some ways I'm like you which I
like a good party probably not to the
extent cuz I love my wedding like I have
great memories of my wedding it's not
something I think of all the time and so
I do like to you know when people call
in I do like to call out like listen it
is one day and you're not going to think
about it all the time and the flip side
of that is Sam and I are big on like
renewing of vows so it's like if you
don't did if you don't do everything you
want to do the first go round listen in
10 years re renew your vows it'll give
you something to work towards my husband
and I did a vow renewal at 10 years and
we're going to do another one at 20
years and each one will be nicer and
better listen so just understand like
there's you have room to go up and
that's a great Point that's a great
point I love it I like that conversation
yeah congratulations Vanessa I feel like
you guys will makeing the right decision
I'm not worried about you guys you're
pretty pretty straight the straight line
when it comes to to the money 100% do
you remember there was a Netflix show
that was like the people had the
opportunity to choose between I think it
was 10,000 or $30,000 on a house or a
wedding gosh it was a great concept and
that's basically what that call was but
do remember your wedding is one day your
marriage is a lifetime so do the
marriage counseling beforehand do it in
a year you know all the things like it
is it is one day so don't get too caught
up in it this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
all right you're listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm Jade warshaw this is Rachel
Cruz host of The Rachel Cruz show on
YouTube If you happen to be on there
also smart money happy hour is a great
one um listen Rachel this kind of came
up U several months back I saw an
article where they were just talking
about more more and more people drawing
from their 401ks and from like their
actual retirement um to cover
month-to-month expenses and of course
we've all seen in the news like the
extremes where people pull from their
401k to go see Beyonce or to go see
Taylor Swift right right right but they
and don't do that that's terrible but
there's a lot of folks out there who are
kind of facing that paycheck to paycheck
cycle they're feeling the stress and the
strain of their money and they don't
know where else to go and they're
thinking is it better you know I don't
want to put this on a credit card or I
don't want to take out more debt here's
money that's my money maybe I should
take out from this money and I can you
know make my situation better matter of
fact the guy called the show the other
day he had just had his taxes done and
the fee for the taxes was $300 but his
return was only $100 and he was like oh
crap like I thought I was going to be
able to take some of the money from my
return and he's thinking like maybe I'll
just go to my for matter of fact the tax
guy not one not one of our trusted Pros
but the tax guy that he was working with
told him hey why don't you go to your
401k and take out a loan so people are
just tossing this around as an option
like it's just nothing here um and I
need people to understand that if you
withdraw from your retirement you're
going to have to pay a 10% penalty on
that money that you take out and by the
way if you happen to draw from your 401k
if you lose your job that money becomes
due like almost immediately and you've
got a year to pay it back before you
start facing more fees and penalties so
this is more serious than what people
really are drawing into it um it says uh
I'll get to that part in a minute but
what I want people to I read an article
that said the average withdrawal Rachel
is about $55,000 like people aren't
looking to get
$30,000 it's not tens of thousands on
average it's five it's $5,000 and do you
know what I figured out Rachel that if
you took a less than average car
payment that you that's basic basically
the $5,000 like if you went a year
without your car payment you'd have the
$5,000 for sure or you did a side hustle
for $1,500 a month you could get it yep
so I kind of um want to have some
empathy for the fact that people feel
like they're faced against a wall right
that there's no other thing but what I
want you to see is listen start looking
around because there's there's other
options and avenues for you to get out
of this well and in that case it's it's
such a um we see this all the time if
you're in a crisis or you feel like you
have no options it feels like this is
the only choice this is the only money I
have so even if it's $3,000 $5,000 I'm
going to I'm going to do that and it's
such a shortsighted view versus pausing
letting the chaos settle right and
actually formulating a plan and when you
actually start looking at other options
so it is that that quick kind of grab of
like oh my gosh I got to just yeah yeah
have it it's it's tough and some people
are like listen I'm having a hardship
and there are you know there are
hardship withdrawals uh hardship means
that uh let it allows you to take money
out of your 401k to meet an immediate
and heavy Financial need that's what the
IRS says immediate and heavy financial
and so many of us would look could look
at that and go listen I needed those
Beyonce tickets whereas others will look
at it and go okay yeah I've been without
my you know I've been without a job for
x amount of months or you know what
we're saying is this could include
something like a natural disaster right
repairs to from a natural disaster
covering funeral expenses for a loved
one um paying rent to avoid being
evicted like those are really really
serious situations uh you're only
allowed to take out the exact amount
that you need for those expenses and
remember you you'd still have to pay
taxes on it so there's really no way
around um some of the financial um
strings that are attached to this even
if it was a hardship withdrawal and
again um we're seeing that these are on
the rise unfortunately more and more
people are lying about their situation
Rachel to qualify to get it which is for
o that's fraud yeah legal y y we don't
want to do that so um what we just want
you to take away from this is a don't
lie about your situation and don't
commit fraud but B understand that
there's always options um there's always
a way that is better than probably what
your scared and anxiety filled Sleepless
brain is coming up with in the moment
right that's right because when we're
panicked we're like okay what can I do
what can I do and your brain just
fixates on one thing that usually feels
like the easiest answer that feels like
the answer with the least amount of
friction but a lot of times it's not the
best answer like it might be what we
talked about you picking up a side
hustle in the midst of an already very
busy schedule you selling a car and
having to coordinate with your spouse a
onecar situation when you've had two
cars your entire marriage like no one is
sitting here and saying that that
wouldn't be difficult or very hard to
pull off or require tons of coordination
but it's bigger and better than
borrowing from your future because what
happens is with when we pull from our
retirement it does draw a line in the
sand of okay this is something that I
have the option to do yeah and once you
start that it's it's it's kind of like
you've said this is this is available to
me and then the next time a hard
situation comes that's an option that
you know you did in the past and so it
really is about building the right
Behavior over time Rachel for me totally
cuz it fixes like you said the issue in
the moments but man it it takes away
from so much growth that could be
happening so do make the sacrifice on
the short term that's why we tell people
not to take money out of your of your
retirement 401k or rth or IAS um to pay
off debt because this is something that
you can do on your own without that
money because again you lose so much so
much growth when you do that so if you
want to know more about this we do have
a really cool article by the way we have
tons of articles on ramsy solutions.com
but we've got one here that's called why
you shouldn't withdraw from your
retirement to pay off debt very there's
a nice ring
but it's at ramsy solutions.com and the
link is there in the in the show notes
so take a look at that it's just listen
knowledge is power the more you know
with a little Rainbow at the end so with
that let's go to the phone lines we've
got Kaden in Boise Idaho what's going on
Kaden hey there how's your guys' day
going great how about you uh terrific so
uh I got myself into a little bit of a
pickle I'm uh 22 years old uh I make
about 880,000
uh I made 880,000 last year I'm planning
on making a 100,000 this year nice and
I'm roughly uh
$280,000 in debt that includes a house a
car a motorcycle and um other
miscellaneous like credit cards and
stuff how much is the house of that debt
uh house is
225 okay and go ahead and just tell me
the rest of them as well the
car uh car is
4,000 uh motorcycle is
12 um and then credit card is another
four and then I have a 4,000 uh home
improvement loan for an electrical
situation that had happened so and
that's four as well listen yeah I think
you do have some debt here that I think
that you'll be able to clean up
relatively quickly I think because
you're grouping it in with the house it
feels even more overwhel in um and that
might be because is is your home payment
too high for your income what's your
home
payment uh home payment is uh I have a
first and a second mortgage I went
through FHA so they did the down payment
assistance um okay first uh first
mortgage payment is uh 1750 second is
100 okay so you're paying $1850 and
what's your take-home
pay um uh roughly uh I I work hour
hourly plus commission so it varies but
anywhere from 4 to like seven month so I
think on most months you're fine with
this mortgage um I if I were you I mean
the way we teach is the mortgage is
completely separate from the rest of the
debt and I think if for right now while
you're in baby step 2 which is paying
off all of your Consumer Debt except
your mortgage I think that'll break it
down into like more manageable
bite-sized pieces um do you have any
money saved
kayen um I do not okay yeah so um if I
were you I would probably sell the
motorcycle mhm I would look to say okay
then that that takes a that takes a good
chunk off then we got 12,000 left uh
between the other the 4,000 car 4,000
credit card and 4,000 um on the
electrical issue and I would just work
to pay that down Kaden I mean I would I
would work extra I would do what you can
I mean you're 2 2 if you get all this
stuff cleaned up uh it's amazing what
can happen when you don't have all this
debt and I would cut up the credit cards
and I would really start living a life
to say okay I'm someone that doesn't use
debt you pay it off you save up an
emergency fund and Kaden at 25 is going
to be uh pretty dang in a great
[Music]
situation
you are listening to the ramsy show and
thank you for listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm Jade horshaw join me join next
to me is Rachel Cruz and we're taking
your calls for the rest of the hour uh
so you can give us a call the number is
5225 I mentioned it before and I'll
mention it again we are doing a really
cool live event coming up May 10th and
11th here on on our campus here in
Nashville Tennessee it's The Total Money
Makeover weekend so it's over the course
of a couple of days you come up here on
our campus and we are going to walk
through really what it's about is it's
based on the book The Total Money
Makeover so that's the baby steps and so
basically everything you hear is talking
about on the radio if you want that deep
dive if you want to be around
like-minded people you want to just get
into it get that deeper level be
motivated this is the event for you um
all the personalities are going to be
there if you've been to a live event
before this is not going to be like the
one you've been to this is completely
different so if you want to get those
early bird tickets they're $99 and
they're only going to be here for a
limited time so you can get those at
ramsy solutions.com
events and uh we'll see you there
without further Ado all right let's go
to Rachel who's in Spokane Washington
the city I was born in what's going on
Rachel it's a pretty all right City I'll
say that
hey what can we do taking my call um I
would love some advice I um it's sort of
financial related kind of not my
finances but I am 32 years old and I'm
an independent parent which means like I
chose to become a parent by myself after
you know I was 25 26 27 couldn't find
anyone we never aligned with like
finances or like Financial ideology or
having children so three years ago I
decided to have a child on my own I love
my daughter she is the best oh my
goodness um I so I feel like I really
need some good decisions and she's a
little older now she's four now and you
know a lot of friends and family are
always asking me like you should start
dating soon like why why aren't you
going on dates like why are you not
doing this and a really big reason so
I'm 32 I don't have any debt I don't
have any credit card debt I paid off all
my loans credit card debt car all that
when I was 26 5 time I was 26 um and a
huge reason is um uh kind of a feeling
of you know there's the obvious you know
not just like letting anyone around my
daughter not just like GNA for sure you
know I don't want to I there's there's
that reason but the reason I'm calling
is that my friend set me up on a date
with one of her work friends or
something um her husband's work friend
and we were just chatting he was like
how do you do it how do you like single
parent it must be so hard and I was like
oh like I don't live with debt I like my
job like it's not really that hard like
it's it's hard if you are like if I'm
like very financially stable and he um
he was like oh I have like I'm like
$450,000 in debt and like all these
things and he started just kind of
naming him this is my first date with
this person I like oh I know a lot about
you um and but we say not to do on a
first dat I know well at least now you
know yeah and I was like maybe this is
my fault because I was just casually
just trying to like keep it lighthearted
like oh I don't live with that but like
to me it's been so long since I've lived
with that that I was like maybe this
maybe people just love talking about
this I don't know
yeah then I was talking to my friend
she's like oh like how it go like you
know I don't really think this is like
for me and when I was explaining like
it's not just about introducing someone
to my daughter's life it's also about
introducing that whatever like sure yeah
I'm not going to date without the
intention of mar
and sure um and I don't know how to
explain and I don't even know if it's
wrong to like not give somebody a chance
KN that they're so we're on totally
different pages and you get to set your
non-negotiables listen you get to set
your non-negotiables you get to have
that list of here are the things that I
really at this point in my life want to
align on and you get to say what that is
and you also get to reevaluate that with
time like listen you could come up with
a list of five things and if you find
out that after 10 years no one is
meeting up to your expectations you get
to decide well maybe I am being a little
too like maybe is there anything that I
can change or is there anything that I'm
being a little too judgmental on and
having
uh listen you guys talked about this
really early in the relationship had you
have had you have dated for four months
and fallen in love and then him sprung
on the the F the $500,000 of debt or
however much it was listen you might
have married him anyway like I did but
but um yeah so I think I think Rachel I
think you have to you know I would go
into it and I
wouldn't I wouldn't um put this you know
thing out there that if if they do have
debts it's a it's an absolute no I'm not
saying you're saying that but what's
important is the value system right so
if they came to you and was like oh my
gosh I still have $100,000 of student
loan debt and I hate it I don't want to
you know this I feel this burden I'm
trying to pay it off like that's
somebody that you're like okay I can get
on the same team we are we are running
in the same direction and I think the
same would be true you know for a
spiritual aspect how you want to raise
kids um you know I mean the in-laws and
family like these are Big Topics in life
and when you marry somebody those topics
Collide and you're not always going to
be the same person you're not going to
marry the same the clone of you right so
you're going to probably always have a
different take a different spin on these
things but the overall direction is what
you're looking for so yeah it I don't I
don't think I wouldn't find someone
really attractive if he's like I got
$450,000 in debt I'm about to go buy
another property and keep leveraging
myself I'm like great for you but that's
just not attractive to me like I can't
you know and I would say the same thing
lines like that with in a spiritual
sense or with kids like right there's
things that you're just like we just
won't be aligned in life so I don't
think you're being too picky I would I
would say you know if you if you called
and said yeah just because he has dead I
won't date him that's no that I wouldn't
say that that's yeah I would not go down
that route but especially if they've
been like and I want to get out of it
right so it's all about where they're
going and what the values are going
forward but um but and I think everyone
has kind of that one subject in life
that they're really passionate about
with the other person right and so
naturally yours might yours might be
money Rachel not from a shallow
perspective but something that you
really cherish your convictions and you
really want to partner in this and I
think that's big the thing to consider
especially with the debt aspect of this
is is let's just say you know you've
gone on four or five dates and it comes
up at Applebee's and you start talking
about it remember there's still time
like you're not getting married tomorrow
so if this guy has $60,000 of debt
there's time for him to pay that off
before you get married like there does
that make sense like if if you're really
feeling some type of way of like man I
really sacrific to pay off my debt I
don't know if I have the stomach to go
through another 60,000 just think about
the fact that there's still a timeline
like you're not getting married tomorrow
and you'll be able to see if this person
really does show and prove what their
values are because are they actively
trying to get out of debt it has have
has eight months passed and they've paid
off nothing you know what I'm saying
like you're you're going to see that
come out in the wash so I I wouldn't get
too too hung up on it um within you know
the first few days or even the first few
months necessarily if you're on the
fence does that make sense that makes
sense yeah I think that something was
just like a of a flag he was like oh I
have all this M's like but the
government's going to cancel student yet
so that's fine no red flag for sure no
no I feel like that for me so maybe I
should have added that and I was like
okay there's one thing to like know
you're at Le I mean some people don't
even know how much money they're in debt
but I felt really bad I was like I felt
really shallow and I know that it it's
one thing to ask for someone to not be
in Deb but this is greeted by you thank
you no I just I just walked away I was
like I have no idea how I feel about
this right now and and I think it's I
think I think give yourself some Grace
too because
$450,000 it's a lot of money even if
he's trying to get out that that is a
it's kind of a you know especially if it
doesn't include a mortgage that's a
breathtaking number so I think that's
fair that you're like oh gosh you know
like that's a that is a lot of debt and
so uh no I don't think you're being too
judgmental I wouldn't I wouldn't count
someone out just because they have debt
it's all about the value system and
where they're going moving forward and
could you see yourself with them in the
future right if they're walking that but
that's and Rachel's you're you're a very
I mean to do what you've done even with
a child you know like at was she 30
years old and I mean all of that like
you that is a beautiful beautiful thing
um and you've made choices in life that
are very mature and you've taken on a
lot of responsibility in life and so I
do think your husband has a high bar and
I don't think that's a bad thing hey in
the chat I I would love when people get
a chance to put their OPP their thoughts
on this in the chat like what your
non-negotiable is
yeah and we can talk about it at some
point because listen after paying off
the debt that we paid off if God forbid
something happened to Sam waran and I
had to get out there in this in these
streets if somebody came at me I don't
know if I could stomach again even like
30k would be like no so everybody's got
their limits Fair that's fair Jade I'd
be interested to know what you guys
think about this throw it in the chats
and uh maybe one day we'll talk about it
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
you are listening to the Ramsay show our
scripture and quote of the day my
favorite whoever picked this knows me
Galatians 51 it's for Freedom that
Christ has set us free stand firm then
and do not let yourselves be burdened
again by the same yoke of slavery one
version says don't be entangled Again by
the same yoke of bondage oo love it in
other words when you get out of debt
don't go back in just putting that out
there
okay and then Janice Joplin says you are
what you settle for oh booya there you
go love it that's good that's good stuff
all right let's go straight to the phone
lines uh the number is 8825 5225 if you
ever want to give us a call we're going
to go to Eric who's in Austin Texas
what's going on Eric hey y'all it's so
great to speak to you guys how are y'all
today happy Friday oh thank you happy
Friday to you oh my goodness you guys
this is great I'm let me take a deep
breath here I'm kind of nervous but
uh hey so I am calling because I started
out kind of in a position like you were
Jade and I had
$215,000 in debt and that was I know it
was a lot uh it was between student
loans uh two cars a credit card uh some
medical bills and whatnot but I'm down
to about
$77,000 now so I've really yeah I've
been really building that snowball but
the uh I've come to the final Mountain
here that final amount of debt that I'm
up to and everything else prior to has
only been like 10,000 or $20,000 and now
I'm facing a
$78,000 mountain so my first question is
what piece of advice do you have for
somebody that has been like really
pushing and really going through this
this uh that snowball method for the
past couple years and it's just like
yeah you know you're
tired how many years has it
been uh I started this in 2020 so I've
been doing this for we're coming up on
four years now and it's been it's been a
lot
listen that is a lot and um four years
is a lot so congratulations let me be
the first one to just kind of like clap
you up and say very good um the 78,000
what is that big chunk what is it that's
all student loans that's all L over for
my student loans yes ma'am o I know the
feeling oh I know the feeling so well so
um the 78,000 let me ask you this is it
one like I I remember ours was one one
payment like it was a chunk of uh 78,000
but if you looked closely it was
actually a bunch of little loans grouped
into that one payment is yours like
that mine is just one giant loan at this
point um I think I worked with my
parents at one point to just uh what do
we do we Consolidated from Sally May
into like a another organization and
it's just one giant sum at this point
with one interest rate and one account
number and one everything right correct
yes ma'am okay so I'm sorry about that
that is tough It's hard to see that the
good news is it's your last one um
probably another set of good news is how
much are you able to chunk away at it
every single
month well that kind of leads me to my
second part of the question is I'm
currently in Austin and and as you know
the tech industry isn't necessarily uh
very reputable for staying consistent uh
whenever it comes to jobs so I've
actually put myself into storm mode
because I believe that my organization
will be doing layoffs here in the next
couple months so that's my struggle is
not only do I have this mountain in
front of me but I also have you know to
kind of put everything aside temporarily
before I can start paying my student
loans again so which I think is smart
that's kind of my predicament it's
probably smart for you to do that um I
want to go back to your first question
which is listen I've been in this four
years what do I do to to stay motivated
right now you kind of have a little bit
of a I don't want to call it a breather
because you're still stacking up as much
money as you can um but what I think is
really important uh and just for anybody
listening you know we say all the time
on here the average person is out of
debt you know in two years or less and
it's important to remember that there's
people to the to the right of that
average number and um my guess is you
know if you continue paying off this
debt you might have another year or two
into this so that you're going to be six
years in which I relate to and I do
think that for for you and anyone
listening you have to have to have to
include Milestones of your own ways that
you can celebrate ways that you can the
way describe it is like a humpback whale
right a humpback whale is swimming along
he's swimming he's going after it he's
doing what and every once in a while he
jumps out and he just like has that
moment of like oo I can breathe and he
goes back in and I think that that's the
way you have to to to navigate this
because we say on here all the time
beans and rice rice and beans gazelle
and Tin you're not going inside of a
restaurant unless you're working inside
like and that's so so true especially
when you're in that average but once you
cross over into the four and five year
mark there is a part of this that
mentally for your health like you need
to go into a restaurant like and and be
I'm being clear like I am not talking to
the folks in average I'm talking to my
sixf figureure freedom folks who have
the sixf figure debt in this case
215,000 you're in this thing for an
above average time four five six years
you need to become a humpback whale and
you need to jump out and you need to do
maybe you did save up cash to replace a
beater Okay like go ahead and replace
your beater if it's falling apart and
you've got 8,000 in cash do it I
remember a Sprint it's a marathon yeah
you're in a marathon and let me just for
the people listening some of the things
that Sam and I did in our debt payoff
Journey which was s and a half years
that was not paying off debt a we uh
cash flowed another vehicle cuz we we it
was time okay we did take a couple of
very small trips like weekenders to like
okay like we're good and again this is
at that four five and six year mark
right you just have to do something that
you've said when we get to this point
we're doing that when we pay off that
next Sally May or Nelnet or naian or
whatever you have when I get to 880,000
I'm doing this and when I get to 100,000
I'm doing this and when I get to and so
you have to set those milestones in
there and set them ahead of time so that
you don't feel the need to uh get sloppy
all right so you've got 78,000 to go I
feel like in that 78,000 there's
probably one one medium to decent
Milestone within that and you've got
probably 2 years to go after a 4-year
Journey sounds like you've been hitting
it pretty hard so how much do you make a
year Eric I make after taxes probably
about 4,800 a month to about 5k a month
okay
yeah so I mean so my goal is to go ahead
oh go ahead I'm sorry no you go I want
to hear what you have to say sure my
goal is to pay it off by the time I'm 30
right now I'm in 28 and a half and so I
just I really want to get after it and
I've been very gazelle intense about
this and I I want to pay it off and I
want to get rid of it by the time I'm 30
but you know it's just 77,000 staring at
staring at that mountain to me and
you're right I need to set those
mileston and I guess I need to be a
humpback whe in the
situ yeah and Eric I like what Jade said
I haven't heard you say this before Jade
but I'm like that is so true be
intentional with those Milestone moments
too because I think there is a point
that you're just so exhausted that
you're like oh and there can be a
sloppiness in the Milestone cration and
you end up spending more than you think
right and so it's like you're being so
proactive it's part of the plan as you
look out that you're like I'm planning
for this at this date this is how much
I'm going to spend here to enjoy this to
get that breath of fresh air to keep on
moving but when you get to the point of
complete exhaustion sometimes then
that's when you're like oh my gosh I'm
going to make you could make some poor
choices out of pure exhaustion if you
haven't planned for it so as intentional
as you can be which kind of takes the
fun of out of it sometimes but like but
it gives you something to look forward
to and it's not a trip to Europe cuz I I
already heard I heard somebody thinking
I can finally take that trip it's not a
trip to Europe it is not a sday vacation
Europe last year what' you say I said
not me taking a trip to Europe last year
uh
oh listen I'm not gonna I'm not going to
go off because I don't know the details
but my point is be a hunt back whale and
since you did take that trip to Europe
this next Milestone is not going to be
quite as extravagant it's going to be
you know I mean it's different for
different people the things that you
value um I know for me it was including
certain things that I had cut off for
such a long time like I was like listen
I'm going to start getting my nails done
again like I it was certain self-care
things that I was like I I'm not doing
this anymore and I've worked really hard
um and so you have to be reasonable and
I mean I can't decide what that's going
to be for you on this phone call but you
have to be reasonable and figure out
what that is for us we had one vehicle
and the the the windows were held up by
Sho strings so it was like listen we've
got the money saved it's time to upgrade
the car and I remember calling in the
Dave Ramsey Show and saying to Dave can
I do this and I think that's what
happens and this shows me that he's in
the right spot when you're just so in it
that you don't even you can't see the
forest for the trees anymore and you
need somebody to tell you that you can
take a break that's a good indicator
that it's time to take a break so good
really proud of job Jade I'm glad you
were here today so good I'm glad you
were here stuff such good stuff we have
fun together again Jade warshaw here
Rachel Cruz you were listening to the
ramsy show thanks for hanging out with
us and make sure you see us on down the
line on the next Ramy
[Music]
show
la